and um I think it's like an important
subject that is often not uh talk about
enough and there's a few reason uh the
first one is that deployment is actually
a very scary process um because you're
basically removing all of that code that
you know actually works and you're
replacing it with new code that might
actually be completely broken for all
you know and you're also changing your
database schema you're killing all of
your process you know it's like probably
the one um uh moment in time where
things can go wrong with your app it's
not like a random failure in your
database server it's because you're
pushing new code that has not been used
by your by users so it's a major cause
of that time and it's also a huge waste
of time for developers because if you
break production you have to fix it or
if your deployment process is hard to
manage then it's time you're managing
your deployment process rather than
writing
code uh so my name is Simon I'm ASM
GitHub and Twitter I work for rainfor
sqa where we are trying to make testing
as easy for everyone and as part of this
uh we spend a fair amount of time
talking to our customers about testing
and how to deploy code Productions how
they endol their staging servers um
and you know we get like a very varied
range of response from this from like
what is a staging server like I just
push my coach production to like yeah
I'm not very happy because I only deploy
20 times per day um so you know we have
bad stories and we also get like a lot
of cool stories from people who actually
have this sorted out very well and the
goal with this talk is to actually
present some of the things we've learned
by doing this and also uh by building
our own application um you know this is
a fairly short talk so I'll go over some
stuff quickly but hopefully you should
all learn something about
deployment um so the first the first tip
which is I think the most important
thing like if you get only one thing out
of this stock it should be this if your
deployment process is more complicated
than this you're doing it
wrong like if you have a script or
multiple scripts to be to run whenever
you deploy thing to
production um somebody is going to mess
it up it's very over prone uh just push
to get use a CI server uh to run your
tests do your build process whatever
needs to be doing and then push your
code production um this used to be very
difficult to do because you needed like
another server you needed genkins or
something similar which is a paint
configure you needed like Ops involve
nowaday there's like tons of really good
Ed C we use Circle C we like them a lot
it's probably going to take you know
half an hour to get this working with
circle very
easy awesome
um uh second tip it's like it's might
seems quite obvious but as I said a lot
of people don't have that have a staging
server and make sure that um it's close
production that it's not running like
on very different configuration uh it's
from my experience it's worth spending
the extra money to make it like very
similar to production like get another
SSL sert get another domain don't try to
like you know save eight bucks a year
and put in a subdomain and then get some
random error later on just make it as
close as possible it's definitely worth
the
money again deployment to it should be
very easy have a different branch uh
configuring your C just push it in
GitHub and you're
done um and you know even better than
get push use pull request to deploy just
do a pull request from your feature
Branch to your staging Branch with
production uh the main reason for this
is that pull requests are a very good
communication tool just a push is not
it's not uh the best way to announce
your team that you're actually deploying
uh pull requests are seen by everyone
there's uh it's easy to add text to it
and it's easy to integrate with third
party services like if chat so you get a
notification in your room everybody
knows about it it's very easy just do
it um now let's move to some more
technical
stuff um I want to talk about deploying
your code without causing downtime in
your
application um this is a very V subject
and I could probably do like an hour
long talk talk about it so I'm going to
focus on what I think is the uh the
aspect of that is often most problematic
to even experience developers which is
which are
migrations um if you're using a
relational data store like MySQL or
pogress um running migration is very
difficult um active records also make it
more difficult and if you're just using
raw SQL especially when you're doing
schema changes there is a few command in
SQL that will lock tables uh or active
record will assume things that are no
longer true after the migration uh got
Ron um so one thing to be aware of is
the active records uh column cache if
you're using the standard rail setup um
and what that is is if you look at uh
this migration here uh we're simply like
removing a column from a table called
users very simple
but the the problem with this code is
that um the migration will normally run
before the new code is actually live in
production so the old code is still
there um and even if it's like a de
dicated column that nothing is actually
reading or writing to
notes active records um builds a cache
of known column when it first starts the
application for performance reasons uh
and that means that every time you do a
update attributes or you're trying to
save a model it's going to try to save
all the attributes back to the database
so if that migration runs and something
else an old old version of the your code
try to save to the database it's going
to try to write to that column you're
going to get an exception it's going to
die so the way to um work around this is
that you can do your deploy in two
phases first you add the column you
override a columns method on user um and
you basically tell rails to ignore the
notes column you deploy that code first
and nothing now nothing is actually
using the notes column um and active
records won't try to write to it and
then you can run the migration after and
you can afterwards just delete that go
back to normal
behavior and that's all there is to
it another tip that uh it seems few
people are aware of that migration I had
was actually bad practice deleting
column is not a really great idea
because it's impossible to truly roll
back um because the data is gone so even
if you recreate the same column you
don't have the data so what I usually do
is I just rename the column to deprecate
it underscore the name of the column
underscore a time stamp of when I done
it I had a time stamp so that I know if
something has been dicated for a month
then I can probably safety delete it
because this data you know we there's no
way we're going to roll back a month old
database um adding indexes uh that's
another problem uh it is worse in
certain databases but um the main issue
here is that if you have a a table with
a lot of data and you add a new index
because sometime you just have to do
that uh
my SQL at least will lock the entire
table for the duration of the index
regation sometime this can take hour so
and you know usually large tables are
large because you write to them very
often so it's probably not a good idea
to lock the entire
thing um so how to get around this well
if you're using postgress it's very easy
you just add the concurrency option to
the create index statement and you're
done it's going to create the index in
the background and it's eventually going
to move over to the new index not much
to it if you're using MySQL however
you're not as lucky um MySQL doesn't
support uh creating indexes in the
background there are ways around this
using different tools uh Pruno toolkit
uh is apparently a very good one I've
never used it personally I've used the
other one which is a open source project
by pH we call online schema change
um this is a very scary thing to do in
production by the way um the way the
schema changer tool will work is that
it's going to take your table it's going
to create a temporary copy of that table
with all the same columns it's going to
add the index on the column that on the
empty table so it's going to be very
quick it's going to then start copying
all the data from the old table to the
new one
but then that process can take
hours so there might be new data added
to it so what it does is that it tells
the MySQL replication log and basically
will replay the replication log on the
new table and then it's going to
basically converge to a state where the
two tables are basically clones of each
other when it reaches that point it
basically locks the old table renames it
to something else and then renames a
temporary table to the name of the old
table so now that you have a table that
is exactly the same as the previous one
but with the index
added this is written in PHP and there's
no it's not a command line tool so you
actually have to script this in PHP it's
not fun to use for having used it many
times I you know it it works I've never
had an issue with it but I I was scared
shitless every time I use it do this in
staging first uh because there's really
it's a very weird tool and it's kind of
like black magic it's like a 10,000 line
of PHP in like one
file um whatever so it I've never read
an issue with it it works it takes a
while to understand how it
works um but you know sometime it's the
the only way unless you want to pay for
like 10 hours of down time to add a new
index to your
database um so renaming
columns well my advice is don't Do It um
this is like obviously not always
possible but there's um renaming column
is kind of like a pain in the ask is you
need to uh do if you want to do it
without
downtime um you have to do a bunch of
tricks to get things to work and if
you're using active record uh often you
can get away with not renaming the
attrib keeping the old column name it
just having like a virtual attribute and
write the virtual attribute rather than
the actual attribute
um if you know sometimes um you don't
have a choice for instance um I work a
project once where we had we migrated
from um I don't remember what but to
some like an authentication system to
devis and device needed a very specific
column name uh for the authentication
token so we actually add rename that
column so what we did and that project
is open source uh we wrote a gem called
No downtime migrations and what this
does is it allows uh you to create a
mirror column so it basically adds a new
column to your database with the new
name you want it sets up trigger so that
if you write to the old one it copies
the data over to the new one and if you
write to the new one it copies the data
back to the old one and then it also
starts a u a synchronous copy of all the
data to from the old column to the new
column so they're now all in sync um and
B basically once you're done with that
you can deploy the new code that use the
new column and then delete the old one
like you would
normally um not a uh easy process but it
works uh and if you cannot afford down
time uh it's the the only way I found to
do
it
um something a little uh more fun now um
having a staging server is nice but what
would be much better is that if you
could have
a on demand SE uh staging server so that
uh if you have five developers they each
get their own staging server or
something that we've built internally at
train for us uh which is called foret
which means fork in French um is
basically a tool that will create you a
new uku environment for each bu request
you make so the way this works is that
it leverages the uh uku Fork command and
every time you make new pull requests
against our development Branch from any
feature Branch basically it Forks our
staging server on uku creates a new one
uh and then once the the new staging
server is up it posts a comment on the
pool request saying here is the URL for
your new staging environment um and then
we can go in there and uh test the code
and it's also like incredibly valuable
when there's a UI change because I don't
know about you but you know I know CSS
pretty well but if I look at a p request
that is purely CSS change I don't know
if it actually looks good or not um and
it it's also you know there's no Clash
when you want to test the staging server
and you might be doing something weird
because you're doing a load test and
you're you don't want to affect your the
rest of your
team um so that's something we built and
it's working pretty well for us uh it's
obviously more difficult if you're not
on auku but uh it's you know if you're
using chefer puppet provision servers
it's clearly possible to do on ec2 or
even with like with any provider you
want you just need to be you know to
invest some times in this and be
creative um there's uh many more things
I wish I had time to cover but
unfortunately this is supposed to be a
lightning talk but if you have like any
deployment issue or you're like not sure
about your deployment process please
come and talk to me after the talk uh
Russell who's uh
my coworker is also here and we love you
know as I said we that's our business so
we love to hear about the problems
people are having and we'll be like
happy to help so in conclusion you know
CI is should be the only thing um
deploying your code um it's also
extremely valuable because there's no
like access to give to people um our
interview proc when we do interviews we
often bring people in for like a week
for trial before we hire them
um so these people can deploy without
actually getting access to our servers
like they would if we were giving them
like Capistrano access or something like
that it's very easy not that difficult
setup um deploying without downtime is
clearly possible it's more work um you
kind of have to decide if you're willing
to pay for you know if it's fine for
your business to have like a few seconds
of downtime every time you deploy you I
would my recommendation would be don't
do it because it's too much Bur under
the developers if you're working on a
like high available product you clearly
have to do it um there's a lot of
documentation online uh around this um
there's also been a few talks even at
this Meetup you know detailing uh this
in uh a lot more than I have um and
finally you know I think you should like
all invest in your uh deployment process
because um it it really pays off and
it's uh one of these things where you
can just put in a few hours and you'll
save like a lot of time uh for your
entire
team